fin
à
bonjour à tous je suis fille quils le
tac tech la commission européenne vous
savez ce que c'est il s'agira de notre
sujet aujourd'hui alors la commission
européenne c'est quoi la commission
européenne est une institution qui
représente et défend les intérêts
communs de l'union européenne et de ses
citoyens elle dispose d'un droit
d'initiative c'est à dire qu'elles
élaborent les propositions de lois
européennes qui sont par la suite
soumise au vote du conseil de l'union
européenne et du parlement européen
enfin la commission se charge également
de la gestion de l'union européenne
c'est à dire quel vin via l'application
des traités et de la législation
européenne
on dit souvent qu elle est la gardienne
décrété qu'elle est chargée de la
gestion du budget annuel de l'union
européenne
qu'elle représente l'union européenne
sur la scène internationale où siège
cette institution
le siège de la commission européenne ce
et trouve à bruxelles cependant les
membres de la commission européenne sont
répartis entre plusieurs lieux de
travail principalement bruxelles et
luxembourg
2 qui est composée la commission
européenne la commission européenne est
constitué d'un président élu pour 5 ans
et de 28 autres personnes on les appelle
les commissaires chaque état membre
dispose d'un seul commissaire dont le
mandat est de cinq ans chaque
commissaire européen s'occupe de
domaines bien spécifiques
cela peut-être la pêche les transports
ou encore la santé
comment sont élus les membres de la
commission européenne le président de la
commission européenne était liée à la
majorité par le parlement européen sur
la proposition du conseil européen qui
désigne son candidat
les commissaires sont désignés d'abord
par les états membres la liste des
commissaires est ensuite adopté par le
conseil européen à la majorité le
parlement européen par la suite approuve
ou non cette liste que fait la
commission européenne pour la réunion la
commission européenne
trouver un programme opérationnel pour
l'île de la réunion sur la période 2007
2013 il s'agissait d'un programme de
développement doté d'un budget d'environ
2 milliards d'euros cofinancé par le
fonds européen de développement régional
le feder les objectifs de ce traité
était de valoriser le potentiel humain
de la réunion en mettant en avant sa
culture son patrimoine et son identité
par exemple développer l'économie
réunionnaise dans l'environnement
qu'opérationnel
organiser le territoire réunionnais en
améliorant par exemple les transports
non valorisons les atouts touristiques
de l'île et coupons filet handicap lié à
notre isolement au niveau de
l'entreprise et de l'économie
la commission européenne représente donc
les intérêts de l'union dans son
ensemble
à bientôt dans un nouvel épisode
faux